here's a story that caught my eye
Philadelphia police have cleared the
Flyers mascot Gritty of any wrongdoing
in an assault case involving a 13 year
old boy
yeah Grady was in trouble because they
said gritti assaulted a 13 year old boy
well gritty has been cleared
ladies and gentlemen yeah that's good
news cleared case you didn't know Gritty
is a friend of our show he's been here
before and I am happy to say
now these conclude ladies and gentlemen
he is back please welcome great let's
get great
kostik yes
great okay
so everybody wants to know how you
holding up pretty I'm doing Craig Conant
thanks for asking yeah truly humbled and
relieved that this is all behind me yeah
well we were glad to hear it gritty and
we hope you stay out of trouble and just
have a great season with the Flyers
thanks so much gonna go for ready
everybody okay you can it's okay you can
go now gritty gritty everybody good wait
can we can we get a stage manager to
help gritty leave just to show them off
please that'd be great all right so
we're gonna have an amazing show tonight
Hey we have a wonderful hold on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah use the angle that's more realistic
we have a great show tonight
so glad that we can make this happen
from your HBO series Curb Your
Enthusiasm comedian JB Smoove is here we
have a great show all around we're going
to take a break and when we come back
we're gonna have a wonderful show so
stick around
TV smoothie
[Applause]